wow Pete you're being like parental
right now it's kind of hot from co-stars
to a full-on romance Chase sweet wonders
gives a rare look at her relationship
with Pete Davidson I've been fortunate
enough to have some great relationships
and you know uh honesty is always really
important in a new interview with nylon
magazine the actress says she and Pete
first bonded on set of their 2022 film
bodies bodies bodies guys I get so
stressed out every time we play this
someone always ends up crying Jay says
they became Fast Friends it was clear
they could work together super well he's
such a pro and acting with him is my
favorite thing she's the best actress
yeah they like working together so much
they're doing it again this time in
bubkus a peacock comedy series Loosely
based on Pete's life you're actually
like surprisingly good at this whole
parent thing really yeah
I mean it's probably because you're so
emotionally stunted and the pair's tight
Bond only Grew From There Chase tells
the mag quote we talk about everything
and we are very open with each other
about everything and it feels like
what's happening in our relationship is
very sacred you run away from people who
love you I don't do that I mean like
she's gonna Crush she has a lot of cool
stuff coming so I had a blast well Pete
and Chase's on-screen chemistry clearly
translated off-screen
can't agree A source told ET last month
Pete was feeling a little overwhelmed at
the Butkus Premiere since there were so
many people there but when he was with
Chase he was instantly comfortable I
mean she's the best our source added the
couple is very in love and so cute
together and Pete he's very into her I
wish a big strong man would win me a
teddy bear you and me both sweetheart
huh she's a sweet girl and they are a
good match
foreign